this is a production of Cornell
University
so good afternoon my name is Ming Andrew
from the other lab it's great pleasure
to be here to present my work but before
I talk about my project I want to do a
quick test so look at the two groups of
the fruits and vegetables shown here
which group do you prefer
so anybody prefer the lemons and
eggplant on the left please raise your
hand oh okay
so anyone like the apples with variable
sizes oh okay so it seems people prefer
more uniform agricultural products so
the shape and sizes informally indeed
matters so here raise a key question
independent of biology and also the
title of my today's talk how do you
organs form with consistent sizes and
shapes so our lab views are above zero
at the model system and the sepal is a
green link like the reason why we choose
e posts include three major parts first
like simple development is relatively
insensitive to the environmental changes
or so we have plenty of samples for
assessing individual plants in addition
supports are very easily accessible for
experiments so to study the Magnusson
about controlling the organization
firmly we firstly use mutagenesis to
disrupt it so we identified one
interesting mutant past too short for
variable organ size and shape - here
shows phenotypes of the balls - flowers
so you can see some simple the smaller
than another worms
I also did quantitative analysis to
further confirm the size variability so
on the right it shows the simple error
distribution of the vast tube is wider
compared to that of wild-type indicating
higher variance so - why the boss why
the Sepoy is more bearable in the past
two million to answer that question I
first thought try to obtain some
insights from the gene function so I did
my best cloning and identify the T - a
point mutation happening in a gene which
encodes meat domain protein and I tried
to express the fluorescent proteins
under the promoter of the gene and found
expression in early flower indicating
the role of the boss - in the early
flower development so then with the help
of the SEM we try to find
stages when we can see the simple
variability phenotypes so for the
wild-type you can see the full support
primordial evenly distributed around
boundary of the flora meristem however
for the boss to flower you can only see
three support primordium and as
indicated with a red arrow clear one see
boys missing at this stage and the
support size variability phenotypes they
be the bulb through late stages so the
supersize variability phenotypes arise
very early and it indicates that the
support initiation might be disrupted to
confirm that I did my best and I did a
live meeting to track the organization
by imaging the same flowers every six
hours
so here shows the representative 10
points from a live imaging so for
wild-type at the beginning we can see
the initiation of the first sepal and
within 12 hours we can see the
initiation of all 4 sepals and after 42
hours 4 sepals cover the whole bud
however for the boss - again from the
beginning we can see the initiation of
the first sepal but after 12 hours still
only one simple beatable and after 42
hours you can start with the initiation
of supports here so the initiation of
also supports is indeed delayed and why
is that so it is proposed that prayer
for my oxen instead of hiding regulates
the organization so here I firstly use
dr5 to check the oxen responses so for
the wild type flowers we can clearly see
four clusters of the deer five signals
nicely correlated with SIBO initiating
positions I then use the TCS to check
the cytokine responses and again we can
see the four classrooms TCS correlated
with SIBO initiating positions so the
oxy and cytokine imbalancing exists at
the Sepoy initiating positions how about
for the boss - so the deer five patterns
become more diffused in the walls to
flower and more importantly the deer
vice signal is much bigger and the TCS
signal is almost for ring around
boundary and seemed strolling hamster so
in the boss - mutant the oxen cytokine
imbalancing is disrupted in
see for initiating positions which might
account for the delayed CIPO initiation
so here is a take-home message we
identified a meep domain protein bus -
which regulates the Ox inside reckoning
balancing during the early flower
development the regulation through the
boss - ensures the robust organization
pattern which leading to leads to the
final getting from organ size you can
find more details in my exist seminar on
March 22nd and all of you I invited and
thank you very much so we have time for
a couple questions so the question is is
only support affecting the mutant or it
also affects our organs such as leaves
so the answer is actually the leave is
much less effective than the sepal but
we also checked like the matter flora
organs like paddle so para lonche is
also affected much as younger than the
leaves but weaker than the sepals but it
seems like it's mainly I mean the
phenotypes mainly focus on the floor of
organs yes I don't know you know whether
it's more difficult but I cancer with my
mutant so in my mutant at the site
opening an oxime disruption actually
will even affect the formation of the
seeds so South Seas will be I will say
it might be even kind of embryo Lisa so
if we dissect the Salix we can say some
seeds actually we can see they cannot
form normally and for some seeds there
may be smaller you can see now it's not
really normally formed I mean so I would
say this gene would also affect the seed
formation and maybe also course on seed
size variability so but I'm not sure how
kind of the Magnusson yes okay thank you
very much
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu